[Musica]
wow
zappi e portare l'arte su un oggetto che
le persone tengono costantemente tra le
mani lo smartphone però con un approccio
ironico e leggero e la società dei
social network ci ha costretti a
ripensare tutta la nostra organizzazione
sociale
innanzitutto perché ormai ci informiamo
e comunichiamo quasi esclusivamente sui
social per cui il nostro mondo non è più
soltanto reale e anche virtuale derivano
una fusione dei due e questo ha
costretto anche a ripensare il rapporto
con le istituzioni
perché le istituzioni per per svolgere
il loro compito sociale e quindi pensare
alla cura e all'interesse dei cittadini
devono essere presenti su questi nuovi
mezzi e adattare il contenuto ai nuovi
contenitori fare le cose vecchie
cioè prendersi cura dell'interesse dei
cittadini ma in modo nuovo anche
utilizzando gli strumenti social e tutti
noi lo abbiamo fatto durante la pandemia
quanti di noi andavano a informarsi sui
canali di instagram facebook dei vari
ministeri soprattutto quello della
salute per comprendere le regole di
comportamento
e questo vale anche per la comunicazione
culturale il covit accelerato questo
percorso per cui per tutti i lunghi
periodi in cui i musei e gli enti
culturali e le istituzioni sono state
chiuse i musei anno avevano bisogno i
soggetti pubblici avevano bisogno di
comunicare con i cittadini attraverso
altre forme e l'hanno fatto con il
digitale
questo
avvalora ancora di più l'idea per cui i
social non sono strumenti sono ambienti
in cui le persone vivono in cui si
fondono esperienze che sono reali e
virtuali in cui si sono emozioni reali e
virtuali che si fondono in un unicum
anche per quanto riguarda riguarda il
contesto culturale e guardatevi questo è
una questione di democrazia in qualche
modo
perché serve ad avvicinare le persone
alla vita democratica del paese ea farli
appassionare a qualcosa a cui
probabilmente non si ha passione rebbero
non tutte le persone conoscono l'arte
appunto o la studiano a scuola e non
possiamo pensare che i musei e l'arte e
la cultura siano rivolti soltanto a
coloro che hanno una formazione
pregressa perché questa è classista e
non risponde alla funzione democratica
che invece hanno le istituzioni pubblici
se nei musei si sta lontani dalle opere
ci sono le barriere protettive i social
ce li avvicinano
avvicinano le opere d'arte perché le
portano sul nostro schermo e questo ci
consente quindi di renderli più vicini
di rendere le opere d'arte più vicini a
riportarlo in dialogo con noi e di
evitare quindi
meccanismi di escluso in arrogante che
potrebbero derivare dal presupporre che
tutti siano interessate dall arte a
prescindere dalla loro famiglia contesto
di riferimento
se la scuola è il luogo perfetto per
studiare arte e la scuola ha una
importantissima e fondamentale missione
educativa
i musei hanno la fortuna di poter
dialogare su più livelli per portare le
vicine a incuriosì per portare le
persone a incuriosirsi all'arte e per
farli appassionare uno di questi livelli
è l'intrattenimento
perché l'intrattenimento il divertimento
ci incuriosiscono attirano la nostra
attenzione e attirare l'attenzione di
qualcuno è il primo strumento necessario
step per farlo appassionare a qualcosa
per cui i musei possono anzi devono fare
i meme di giocare con l'ironia delle
loro collezioni puntando su un approccio
emozionale come fa la royal accademy
postando su twitter un uccellino
disegnato da un bambino di cinque anni
che fa 40.000 like ci dice qualcosa li
storia all'arte no parla in modo
emozionante
oppure è come fa il van gogh dandoci un
approccio divertente mettendo una cosa
ultrapopolare sui social cioè i gattini
nella notte stellata di van gogh e così
porta van gogh nelle nostre vite in modo
più vicino a quello che è sentire ci
scappa una risata
e allora che ben vengano gli influenzale
ben venga di ironia perché i messaggi
profondi si possono passare in molti
modi diversi e uno di questi appunto
l'intrattenimento
l'interesse per la cultura va stimolato
anche attraverso personaggi e linguaggi
vicini al sentire le persone e quindi
anche i meme perché sono contenuti
narrazioni citazioni e riferimenti che
hanno valore sociale per una certa
comunità certo affinché la comunicazione
sia efficace bisogna che risponda ai ai
trend di interesse e alle ai contenuti
di riferimento ai linguaggi di
riferimento di una certa community per
cui dobbiamo avere ben chiaro con chi
vogliamo parlare e dobbiamo essere noi
che vogliamo comunicare qualcosa ad
avvicinarci a linguaggi delle persone a
cui vogliamo comunicare in particolare
alla generazione z e non deve essere il
contrario
in questo senso la comunicazione ironica
rompe una regola sociale per i musei
quella che li vuole tempi e custodi
della cultura accessibile soltanto ai
pochi eletti che sono in grado di
comprenderne e la profondità e invece no
noi dobbiamo rielaborare e stravolgere
dando un nuovo significato dei concetti
che sono radicati nell'immaginario
collettivo dobbiamo usare l'ironia
possiamo usare l'ironia possiamo usare
riferimenti più vari per far sì che le
persone siano attratte da quello che gli
stiamo dicendo
attraverso citazioni che vanno da frasi
e iconografie immagini iconografiche
spaziando
dal trash televisivo
ai film e cartoon cult
all'ultima canzone pop
e a dante
raccontato con lo sfondo musicale di
high school musical
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
oppure si possono raccontare episodi
micologici come il mito di marzia
racconta fatta verso la bulletproof
challenge
[Musica]
il contenuto c'è
lo sforzo di comprensione c'è ma è
filtrato attraverso un qualcosa che è
comprensibile attraverso un trend che è
di riferimento per una certa comunità
quella dei ragazzi che frequentano tik
tok per cui non si tratta di essere
banalizzanti di banalizzare la
profondità di dante di raccontare il
mito in quattro parole si tratta di
essere dissacranti per rendere attraenti
concetti perché poi ci sia uno sforzo
ulteriore di approfondimento che non
dobbiamo dare noi in modo paternalistico
ma dobbiamo permettere a ogni persona di
fare per se stessa
basta con le vecchie generazioni che
vivono alle nuove vi spieghiamo noi la
vita no i ragazzi hanno il loro modo di
comunicare hanno i loro interessi
ma se stimolarli nel modo giusto e
manterranno d'attenzione e si fa ridere
attraverso i riferimenti per quella
certa community e ridere ed islam questo
stesso perché ti permette di accedere a
qualcosa senza intermediazione dello
studio per questo non dobbiamo tenere
temere la contaminazione tra settori
arte letteratura e linguaggio pop
riferimenti pop possono convivere
ad esempio
partecipando alle abbuffate di natale
opposto natale con un video divertente
ma di sicuro no
questo per dirvi che il divertimento può
guidare le persone verso temi
sconosciuti può essere una porta di
accesso e di qui poi ognuno farà quel
che crede potrà rimanere su un livello
superficiale o potrà andare approfondire
e ci servirà anche per creare la futura
comunità dei visitatori tutto questo la
comunicazione ironica il contaminarsi
con il coni linguaggio pop invitare gli
influencer serve a rendere il museo i
musei un'istituzione viva e rivolta al
pubblico del futuro
e i social sono soltanto uno degli
strumenti per realizzare la missione
culturale dei musei ma è uno strumento
che deve essere in considerazione
affinchè si riesca poi a trasformare il
dialogo virtuale in una visita reale ea
creare così la comunità dei visitatori
del futuro e ancor prima di cittadini
consapevoli del valore e della fragilità
del nostro patrimonio culturale
perché come vi ho detto prima essere
consapevoli a conoscere qualcosa è il
primo necessario passaggio per
prenderselo a cuore e valorizzarlo e
allora se le giovani generazioni non
conoscono il nostro patrimonio non solo
interessata all'arte come potranno poi
un domani forse ne carico curarlo e
trasmettere il patrimonio epater munus
dono del padre qualcosa da prendere
conservare trasmettere alla prossima
generazione è in prospettiva
intergenerazionale
e quindi
nonostante ci possono essere critiche ci
saranno sempre
non lo sa che si possa sbagliare
e gli errori servono a imparare a
migliorarsi non dobbiamo
soltanto per questo
non provare a metterci in gioco ea usare
degli strumenti
che ci avvicinano a pubblici nuovi e più
ampi
i social ci permettono di avvicinarci a
persone che altrimenti non riusciremo a
raggiungere e non possiamo bollarli come
superficiali soltanto perché utilizza un
codice di comunicazione
che non conosciamo che non ci appartiene
guardiamo con sospetto e che potremo
priori bollare come superficiale essere
disruptive dissacranti serve per passare
il messaggio culturale usare i social
come strumento per raggiungere un fine e
questo fine è un fine di
democratizzazione dell'arte è un fine
culturale grazie
[Applauso]